automobilisme encore mais pour une
première cette fois avec le nouveau
modèle citroën la gs que la firme
française commercialise ce mois ci et
qui se situe entre l'ami 8 et la ds ce
modèle est appelé à devenir le véhicule
de grande diffusion chez citroën
la présentation de cette dernière nous a
été rendue possible grâce à l'obligeance
de la nouvelle concession citroën qui
vient de s'ouvrir à arles et c'est en
camargue bien sûr que nous avons fait sa
connaissance
[Musique]
le moteur est un 4 cylindres à plat
opposés 2 à 2 à arbre à cames en tête
doté d'un refroidissement à air la gs
est une traction avant technique
affectionné par site wenn depuis fort
longtemps déjà
boîte à quatre vitesses synchronisée
elle possède quatre freins à disque est
assisté par le système hydraulique
[Musique]
quant à eux
et ses performances sont plus que
valable la vitesse maxi est donné à 149
km heure pour une consommation moyenne
de 7 à 8 litres à 80 km/heure de moyenne
le tableau de bord est sobre tout en
étant complet
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
la route
après l'arrêt
la direction de la gs c'est extrêmement
précise et la liaison au sol a été conçu
pour obtenir une parfaite et grande
rigidité
[Musique]
ligne fonctionne l original ligne
aérodynamique dans le style de citroën
la gs offre une visibilité parfaite et
une habitabilité excellente
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
la citroën gs c'est également une
voiture qui ne recule devant rien même
devant des taureaux de camargue qui en
étaient les premiers surpris
[Musique]
sa mère
baa
papa
[Musique]